you look amazing you look fantastic i
dressed up for you
i thank you no seriously you look
absolutely gorgeous
uh and i've been talking to everybody in
during kovid
and i have to say you're killing it
right now you do not look like you're
suffering through
a quarantine or a pandemic you look
amazing
thank you i'm definitely trying not to
gain weight i did gain a little weight
but then i think i lost it i mean i
think my goal is just don't gain weight
basically
really are you do you get obsessive
about that or you're just oh
no but my boyfriend started cooking and
everything he wants to cook is really
fattening you know chicken tikka masala
and pizza
and so um yeah but really now wait a
minute i've always
been jealous of men that could whip
something up in the kitchen
i could never ever do that it is cute it
is cute but
yeah i mean i think men find it really
sexy when women cook too right
uh well we're just monsters i don't know
that we find it i mean
my wife cooks but i don't know that i
find it uh sexy as much as it's just
i need to eat a lot all the time
so it's just uh yeah i wish i could
think well you need a lot of energy
right
i'm so tall i'm like a nuclear reactor
i've got to burn so much fuel
uh you know i want to ask you something
because
you famously in uh boogie nights
which is one of my all-time favorite
movies as roller girl you're on roller
skates the whole time and then you
just brought it back on tick-tock yeah
yeah well there's all these really cool
girls you know
um roller skating during the during the
pandemic i was getting really inspired
by them because they look really hot
it looks fun and i just wanted to get
back out there but it's very hard
you know when i first learned i needed a
coach because it's hard
and it's very easy to just fall over and
kill yourself
and also i would think you had to act on
roller skates
you had to you had to perform and also
you were on wheels the entire time which
sounds to me
next to impossible i mean you pulled it
off beautifully but i can't believe you
didn't know how to roller skate when you
got that roll
no i mean it was so fun and then you see
these girls now they roller skate
backwards and they just make it look so
easy so i tried to do that and it was
very hard you know and i live in new
york and it's
it's not that easy to find just like a
quiet street where there's
no cars right so what you're saying is
during quarantine basically how you're
getting around in manhattan is on roller
skates you're just everywhere
only on roller skates no but every time
you hit a bomb i actually bike
everywhere that's what i do i just bike
everywhere but roller skates is like if
you go over like a rock or there's like
an uneven piece you're just like
you know it's so easy to just wipe out
basically